Martina
Patrick Sawyer
a senior journalist at the telegraph who
produced a piece about me
some time ago
a completely libelous piece where he
misrepresents me
completely in fact forget about just
misrepresenting me he misrepresents the
entire situation
in Leicester between the hindutva and
the Muslim people let's take a look at
what he looks like
because it's already on the public
record he's got a an open Twitter
account there's no problems here in fact
he was showing pictures of me as well in
fact mentioning where I live
I think he lives in Middlesex London
just to return the favor to him since he
has tried to expose where I live no
problem you live in Middlesex London I
think it is anyway
no matter this individual will now have
to present himself
in a court of law
because he is officially being sued now
whether or not he wins the case
is aside the point the fact that you
decided to misrepresent me in the ways
that you have
means now that you will be
inconvenienced with a court case
but what wouldn't be known is that I
actually gave you an opportunity to make
reasonable retractions I recorded the
conversation that I had with you in kind
and in that conversation I went through
piece by piece
what exactly was misrepresentative about
that article
the first thing I said to you as you can
hear
will you be able to hear is that I have
never
and will never
or don't have the time or any kind of
inclination
to attend supposed
anti-jewish protests
the only ever protests I've attended
or spearheaded or been a party to
are pro-palissinian protests and unless
in your mind
the two Notions are equivalent
then this is nothing but pure
misrepresentation and in fact not just
that it's a clear attempt by the media
to employ
this kind of
censoriousness
or to create a culture of sensoriousness
for individuals who are activists for
the Palestinian cause by labeling them
with the worst kind of labels I have to
break it to you not only is this unfair
is it illegal in this country for you to
say something like that but also
it is something which now demonstrates
your desperation and the fact that
you've lost the argument
the fact is this
I have had conversations with Jewish
people debates with Jewish people
debates with Zionist people countless
debates
countless debates
and all of them were favorable to me as
you can see with the hundred actually
not hundreds of thousands I would say
tens of millions of people who have
viewed such debates I've even produced a
book on the matter of Zionist terrorism
and so after the public
have seen this and millions of people
have been affected
and that the white top the intellectual
white towel has been thrown in
this is what you have to resort to Now
isn't it you now have to resort instead
of trying to defeat me with facts
and scholarly references and citations
now it's anti-jewish okay
even though there are unequivocal
statements on this very channel of me
speaking against anti-Semitism but let's
disregard that not even mention that and
refer to me as answer Jewish does that
you do you think you have
proven yourself to be victorious
in so doing or is this a great defeat
for you
and for for all I know you're you are an
Italian man
you're an Italian man you've got you've
got no dog in the fight anyway but of
course you're working for the telegraph
and the telegraph has its own history
secondly
you mentioned other things in the
article which I explained to you I've
never said you say he's a
self-described scholar
or self-proclaimed scholar
I've never made such Proclamation
and I explicitly told you on the phone
that that was the case you lied again
and said yes I found it on your website
you will not find any such statement on
my website now you may see this is a
point of triviality
but it's not trivial for me because if
you're a journalist who's Integris the
point is you're meant to be able to
quote things properly
and if you're incompetent negligent
foolish
low IQ to the point where you can't even
copy and paste things properly something
at year 10 can do a competent year 10
can do forget about that even a year
eight or nine can do
in this country then what are you doing
as a senior journalist in something like
the telegraph
thirdly
he actually starts speaking about my
relationship with my father
I want to know why and he says I spoke
to a close relative
by the way you couldn't have spoken to a
close relative because I don't have many
close relatives in this country
and in fact the ones that I do have in
this country were broad for the most
part and it's impossible for you to have
such information in fact if you had
spoken to a close relative can you
please reveal the source because I'm
telling you that it is practically
operationally impossible but for you to
include a section on an article related
to Hindu hindutva Muslim tensions about
my relationship with my father not only
demonstrates the height the epitome of
desperation shows the public the extent
to which you
are trying to spin smear or you're
involved in the smear campaign against
me
but now you've become famous
yes not only inconvenienced
you thought you could put up this
article you and Catherine Lau let's take
a picture of C Catherine Lau for some
reason she is someone who's on this
article she hasn't contacted me at all
she didn't do any of her own checks
checks at all so she puts her name on an
article like this I know that she is a
feminist maybe she's agitated by my
anti-feminist views maybe she is
agitated by me somehow or some reason
maybe she wants to maybe maybe maybe
she's just trying to get climbed you
know the career ladder
what people will do nowadays to climb a
karelada what's next we're going to do
next for climbing career ladder transmit
somebody a community not mention the
fact that there's a hindutva problem in
Leicester which is a far right
radical
organization that if anybody knew
yes if anybody knew if its roots
connected to the RSS
the second Chief of which actually
praised the Holocaust and called for one
all of that has been is conspicuously
absent in your article but you want to
focus on Muhammad hijab and his
relationship with his father
do you think this is good reporting and
good journalism is this in the public
interest
I don't think this is in the public
interest but both of you collaborated on
this point so I'm wondering why
Catherine Lau
why you put your name to such a thing
didn't you think it would drag you down
as well did you think there would be no
consequence to such
a written piece did you think there'll
be no legal consequence no PR
consequence you're dealing with a public
figure
who has a viewership
which is comparable to the telegraph
itself
are you mad
did you think there was not going to be
a response
how can you throw stones when you live
in a glass house
your viewership is restricted to the
United Kingdom
our viewership is not restricted to the
United Kingdom now you've become famous
in all kinds of countries
you go to Malaysia somehow isn't that
Patrick Sauer isn't that the liar
you go to uh any Arab country oh it's
not the liar
that tried to defame
one of our guys
well
even if you go to Italy you're ashamed
to journalism you are a disgrace the
journalism you're a disgrace to the
Italian people the Italian people the
good Italian people in fact you've put
us in a position
where you have made the people see the
extent to which the new Mavericks
the new outcasts are in fact this Muslim
population in Britain
why are you so desperate to paint them
out in a bad way
because you know
you know that Islam and Islamic
civilization
is something which you're trying to put
your foot on it's the sleeping giant
which if it wakes up
all kinds of things will take place
you're trying your best
but we are now the resistance the legal
resistance
and I say this from a
movement perspective
we are now
like the farmers in Italy so now we you
put us on a bad mood Patrick's hour
and now I'm sorry to say I'm worried for
Italy maybe it's going in a fascistic
direction hopefully it's not
but uh
we have become the Mavericks now the
anti-established Mavericks the Muslim
people and you're helping us
create this image
so what I have to say to put us in a
good mood
is
foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]